Democratic senator Kamala Harris of
California joins us now from Capitol
Hill only on CBS this morning she is a
member of the Senate Judiciary Committee
and will be part of Monday's public
hearing senator good morning thank you
so much for joining us you are
California's attorney general a former
prosecutor would you be able to bring a
case like this 36 years old to trial
potentially but you know I think that
the issue here is that this is not about
necessarily a criminal investigation
this is also about what we need to do
around a background investigation into
who Brett Kavanaugh really is the
American public deserves to know the
character of someone who will serve for
his entire life on the highest court in
our country and I think one of the
issues that is getting a bit conflated
here is the distinction between a
criminal investigation and a background
investigation I want to know about this
guy's background and the American public
wants to know about his background we
need to know are we about to put
somebody on the United States Supreme
Court who committed a sexual assault so
the FBI has done six background checks
are you calling into question the
integrity of the FBI no I don't think we
have to go there Norah I think that the
issue is that the FBI needs to do a
background check on this particular
issue and provide it to the United
States Senate who has a constitutional
responsibility to advise and consent on
a nominee to the our highest court who
will again serve for his lifetime
senator Harris this is a classic he said
she said case somebody isn't telling the
truth he says he wasn't even at the
party so what is your process to
determine who's telling the truth here
well listen I think it's gonna be about
it comes down to credibility to your
point gale and it's gonna be about
listening to what each party has to say
but I believe her listen first of all
anybody who comes forward at this point
to be prepared to testify in the United
States Senate against someone who is
being nominated to one of the most
powerful positions in the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage and frankly you know I
have personally prosecuted sexual
assault cases and my concern is and she
knows this
she is putting herself out there knowing
that they're gonna try and excoriate her
and she's doing it I believe because she
knows that this is an important matter
it's a serious matter who serves on that
Court and she has the courage to come
forward she was nothing the game so
sudden she comes again so given those
concerns would you ever put a crime
survivor on the stand let alone before
the American people without first doing
an investigation I believe that there's
that the FBI nor to your point it should
be compelled to do its job in terms of
doing that completing their background
investigation and that's not being done
and the White House is not directing it
the Department of Justice is not
directing it I'm not faulting the men
and women of the FBI I think we have an
extraordinary amount of talent in that
agency who are really well equipped to
do this kind of investigation but
they're not being given the authority to
do it that's the concern I have let me
be clear about it the statistics are
clear you know there's been a lot of
talk about well why is she now coming
forward why did she report over 60
percent the sexual assault victims never
report the crime against them and
usually there is something that
precipitates it later
triggers there they're there they're
feeling responsibility to report what
this isn't a court of law
and so I wonder what the standard is
here for you and also just is it
possible that while everything she feels
is absolutely firm in her bones that she
may just have the wrong guy I think that
we're gonna all be able to judge her
credibility when she testifies before
the United States Senate but I believe
her you know she's pretty specific about
the the the structure of the house where
it happened she's pretty specific about
who exactly was involved you didn't just
name one person she's two senators no no
no I've read the letter in the culture
right now we have two conflicting things
in justice we have on the one hand
people who aren't listened to who are
accusers on the other hand we have
people go to jail because they've been
wrongly accused so those two things to
be colliding in a place where it's awful
difficult because the politics to get
things straight how's that all gonna get
sorted out
and get to the truth and have procedural
fairness well John I think that listen
this comes back to the point about
ordering the FBI to do a comprehensive
and complete background check
I am I strongly believe that the FBI and
and in particular the people in the FBI
who have the experience of dealing with
sexual assault cases should be charged
with doing an investigation and again
this is about this guy's background it's
not about proving a crime it's about his
background I have had many cases where
there was enough evidence to believe
something happened but not necessarily
prove it beyond a reasonable doubt in a
courtroom but it doesn't mean it didn't
happen the United States Senate needs to
know who's this person Brett Kavanaugh
really is no that's the issue and
senator this is when you talk about
character tell me the calculus for you
then if this happened there's also of 36
years of behavior or 30 odd years of
baby or subsequent to that that's also
happened how do you weigh those well I
think that we need to look at everything
that is in his background I mean that's
the whole purpose of having this process
and let's also be clear that the process
has been flawed from the very beginning
they've been pushing through this
nominee without a complete vetting let's
not forget that we have only been
presented with 10% of all documents that
are available about his background
consistently this process has been about
pushing something through without a
complete and thorough vetting of who
this guy is and without Monday United
States Senate on Tavares we'll all get a
chance to hear what both sides have to
say we thank you again for joining us
this morning thank you thank you guys we
appreciate your your work thank you